welcome back to the walleye podcast i'm
james marshall and as
always shout out to our partners
puresport cbd
how good is this stuff and fortune
favors what a brew
and head over to www.waterlab.com to
receive
a discount for either of those two
products okay today i pretty much have
the perfect water lad guess firstly he's
an absolute lad
secondly he's had an incredible rugby
career winning premierships heineken
cups world cups
he's also captained his country as well
as representing the british and irish
lions but most importantly
he's used his profile to make a positive
difference to this world with his
foundation and charity work
it is the great lad himself louis moody
welcome louis thanks for coming on lad
pleasure mate what an intro but it's uh
that's made me feel really special
mate that's always the goal now you can
start sharing your unbelievable journey
and look what i've been reading all last
night the great mad dog book
louis moody what a book what a purchase
i bet you got to you got to do a lot of
coloring in there didn't you there's a
lot of pictures a lot of coloring in
doctor doc oh the boys want me to read
that every night oh they love it they
love them their dog book
it's one of those you know i i wrote
that and uh
it was it was just after the 2011 world
cup which obviously wasn't uh
it wasn't a great success for us and uh
you know we were obviously there
together afterwards right and uh
but i i remember writing that book
thinking right i wanted to i want to be
as honest as possible
because i don't want to i don't want to
do another book because it took like a
year and you sit down you go through
everything it's made
i don't know what you're like but i find
it hard to remember you know what
happened last week let alone what i did
you know 10 years ago in my career so it
took a long time to get this book
together and then
i was like i want to be really honest
i'll be really honest and when you put
it out and and you read it back for the
first time
you press sort of go and and then you
pause for a second
and remember that your mum's going to
read it and and some of the stories you
wish you could sort of just
take back why did i say that why did i
say that
but yeah bye-bye don't read it two kids
it is a great book though can you still
buy it must have been number one for
ages was it
if we'd won the world cup in 2011 it
might have been that no
because we got absolutely destroyed uh
not only on the pitch but but off the
pitch it
yeah no it it it did all right but it
was uh
i think you can find it in the if you're
lucky in the bargain basement now
uh tends to tends to be used denser
views a lot of kindling to start fires
well maybe after this podcast and you've
given them a wee snippet of your life
they can
go back and repurchase that book and you
might set it back up on the charts again
because this podcast is massive
well mate i've been i've been watching
it from over here i've been uh i have
been enjoying it obviously
you know global jimmy maher superstar
and all that
anyway you talked about your memory and
struggling to remember
for your book um the interesting thing
that came has come out recently is
i think your ex-teammate and mate um
stephen thompson
is looking to sue world rugby um what
are your thoughts on that
well i don't know i don't know what it's
been like over there or in the southern
hemisphere but
over here there's been a there's been a
super big push on on all the concussion
stuff over the last few years and
obviously they had
we had all that with world rugby right
was it uh chris nowinski who's
the american football guy that came over
and
was really pushing it hard i think he
was the guy that first broke it with the
with the nfl
and there's been massive changes made
right so which is all being good for the
game and sort of wishing that
it happened when i was playing you know
i might remember some more of my career
but
um you know so thomas said talking about
steve thompson
particularly and that was a it was an
alex popham who was a it was a welsh
international as well so those were the
the two main guys that came out and and
i roomed with tommy for a long time
top man and i had no idea still you know
speak to him
relatively frequently yeah um
so so i was surprised and it was uh it
was a big shock and a i was very sad
to hear that he'd been diagnosed with
early
onset dementia essentially which is what
my my dad just passed away from and he'd
had that for 10 years but he was
you know 78 rather than um you know 42
so having seen what it does to
the individual and and then the the
impact it has on family and carers so
firstly just really you know really
upset for him but
uh i you know where do you go from there
you know i've listened to uh i listened
to um
the rpa over here so the rugby players
association
did a did a webinar on on this because
there was a lot of hysteria and media
and stuff at the time
and they had some scientists on there
which was great you know people giving
this guy called dr willy stewart who's
who's
doing a lot of research into uh
cte which is the uh yeah which is the
the stuff that you find in your brain
right and when it gets bashed around
um and he's doing a lot of research um
so he was on and there were a few other
um top doctors and
clinicians on talking about it and they
said essentially the the risk of getting
dementia
in the normal population i think is
really low
at the minute but he said the risk of
getting um dementia as a
as a sports person is is no different
um so i suppose that was quite nice to
hear you know right because it is
concerning you know i generally
yeah i i had a lot of concussions jimmy
i know you avoided tackling like the
plate so you probably were fine
too skillful mate you're too skillful
could never be caught
but um but yeah i got banged up i got
banged up all the time so
as i know a lot of players in my era did
and so you do you do sort of worry about
it
not not in a way like that it hampers
my life or anything but it does you know
it crosses my mind every now and again
so
i think it was quite a relief to listen
to these
you know eminent professionals talk
about the realities of the risks and
actually there's
um the information they from from what
they were talking about saying there's
no greater risk at the minute from what
they know
for sports people to be any more
prevalent to getting dementia but they
they didn't say that obviously
repeated concussions or bounce to the
head isn't going to have a
you know an impact you know do you feel
like it's had a massive
impact on your memory like obviously
your memory is pretty shot do you think
that's
due to your rugby career um you know i
i i sort of play around with it a bit
with the whole memory thing because
you know i do i've always struggled to
sort of remember stuff and and it's
sometimes an easy way of uh
you know if you're losing track or if
you need to take the the piss out
yourself a bit for a minute just to get
with a laugh it's an easy way of doing
that isn't it
but uh i have struggled with it on and
off but i i couldn't say that it was
definitely because my rugby but you
don't regret you don't regret um
playing professional rugby do you no not
at all not at all
and a lot of the guys you know and
tomorrow included came out and said that
you know he
you know if he'd known he he wouldn't
have played but it's not you know
and i'm sorry to hear that that's how he
feels but that's not the case for me
mate i
i love the game there are risks in
everything you do right i knew there are
risks in playing rugby
um you get injured you get banged in the
head you know all sorts can happen but
the the life that it afforded me the
opportunities it created and
you know the things that it taught me
absolutely no i have no
no regrets whatsoever you know i love i
love the game it's
just one of the most awesome
things i've got to do during my life you
tackled with your face a fair amount
throughout your career
and obviously there's a game against
tonga where you had a couple of real
brutal head knocks uh was that the worst
concussions you had and talk to me about
that experience
mate well to be fair like so that again
is a guy
playing for tonight called nearly later
he was a great player and he came over
and played for newcastle over here for a
while as well
um and i'd been out of the team brian
ashton was the england coach at time and
he didn't rate me very much so
i was sort of benching for the first
three matches that was my first start
against tonga
so desperate to impress and uh and flew
out the blocks
tried to try to charge down the full
back
um i mean my technique was whenever you
boys uh
like like when we first met right on the
pitch you're playing for
cavazano irony
that's it quality um
one of the biggest games of your career
hasn't it yeah
mate i remember briani calling me and
saying please don't hurt jimmy please
don't hurt james i think yeah
i think she was genuinely scared i was
going to get hurt by you because she
said the same thing to me she's like oh
watch out for lewis he's just like he's
a psycho
i'll say don't you worry he won't last
and then about 20 into the game
i missed the six nations because of that
bloody game but yeah i
didn't get near you either which is
really disappointing because i
you know when bryce called me i was like
right again he's definitely getting it
twice as hard i didn't get anywhere near
i don't think i made one tackle on you
that probably means that you just passed
it a lot rather than run
i don't think we had the ball to be fiat
was at 60 nil
[Laughter]
yeah i scored i scored one trying that
again from a pushover for about three
meters out it was an absolute gem
look what a beaut wanted to remember but
hey look so that that that tonga game it
was that was the first that was the
first time post match that i'd ever
really genuinely appreciated what
concussion was about so
a child just kicked down got it
completely right well i didn't get it
wrong
i got i got to him i missed the i didn't
get the ball
but i got his uh i got his leg his leg
actually kicked my
leading arm yeah and my my own hand
then ended up going in my eyes my thumb
went in my eye
and uh and i went blind sorry no no what
am i talking about that was a
that was a totally different one that
was gloucester that was buffy gloucester
[Laughter]
2007. so it was a charge down but i got
his knee right in the in the temple
i don't i don't know who he was but it
was his tongue on full back and i was
out i was out cold on the floor and i
remember as a
young lad playing for his called matthew
tate who's a wonderful player
and he was like 21 at the time and i
remember
lying on the floor thinking why is he
why is he talking so strange because he
was saying my name like really slowly
like
that was my nickname and um and then i
realized that i was actually lying on
the floor like
not moving and he was trying he was
trying to help me up literally so i was
out
and it was back you know it's back then
when it was
concussion was not understood properly
and you had
virtually no protocols any protocols you
did had you could work your way around
can you
by you know we i think we had to do the
work the hardest i ever got was you had
to
you had to say the months of the year
backwards you know which i'd struggled
to do
when not concussed quite frankly so i
mean
why they come on and ask me that but um
but yeah basically i just i just you
know blacked my way out of it back then
you could you know you could just the
the decision was in the player's house
right and
i just sort of pushed the dock off and
going out i'm fine let me back on
ran around second half no end of the end
of the first half
nearly latu i got a short ball off
johnny wilkinson
and uh it got absolutely smoked in the
head
so just came flying through his like
chin and chest
and and i was out again in the next the
next day so we won't convince me i
actually played a really good game you
know i don't
recall any of it but i played a i played
a really good game and the next day
so the first real recognition and
time i sat back and went okay this is
something that needs to be
taken more seriously we went we ended up
going to euro disney
and um we had like the day off it was it
was before
so i think it was the last maybe it was
the last game of the
of the pool i can't remember so we're
then building up to the court final
um and we went on these roller coasters
at euro disney and i went this thing
called the black hole
and literally it got in and annie was
like you probably shouldn't go on this
you know with those concussions yes i
don't know i'll be fine it'll be fine
i've never had a problem
wow mate went on literally first drop i
was like that
get me off get me oh i was awful my head
like
my head was exploding and you know
i can laugh about it now thankfully but
at the time it was awful
and it made me it made me look back and
go i spent the worst bit about it was
but then i had to spend the rest of the
day like
following everyone around all the lads
and the girlfriends carrying essentially
carrying the girls bags handbags because
i couldn't do anything um yeah it gave
me a whole new found respect for
for how you how you deal with the
concussion right and i am
i am really glad that all the protocols
are in place now because the lads
you need to be looked after like you
don't know what impact that sort of
stuff is going to have on you
so um you asked me earlier would i go
back and change anything we were
operating with what we understood at the
time you know the medics were operating
with what they understood at the time
and as a player quite frankly i didn't
want to come off the pitch
yeah so you know i'm glad they had to
change the rules to put the power in the
medic's hand and the doctors not not the
players
i can't believe you went on a roller
coaster after a double head now yeah
yeah it's not not my best decision did
you play um
in the quarterfinal the following week
or did you have a couple weeks off at
least
uh no no no but played every game so
you know i uh so we started the start
against australia the following week
and again all you had to do was pass the
the computer test right which everyone
so i don't know whether you did it jimmy
yeah so you you did like a bass test
prior to let's say the match so you did
it on monday
yeah and then if you got concussion
you'd do a second test afterwards
but so i mean if you passed if you
passed that then then you're fine but
you could always
you could you could scan them right
because you could just do a really
rubbish bass test when you first did it
pretty much what all the players
yeah yeah so it was yeah it would and
when you look back it's not cool but
that's just again it was it was what we
what we operated in and concussion was
not treated like a big issue for
whatever reason when we played right so
we didn't necessarily take it seriously
and we wanted to play we didn't we
didn't want to miss a game you know it
was a quarter final world cup you know
lucky mate i was lucky i got to play in
three
you know if you get to playing one the
last thing you want to do is is
get a head bang and then miss the
quarter final obviously now we know
it's different you know sort of jack uh
jack knowle of england you know miss
he missed the premiership final and a
heineken cup final because of
a had knock you know so now it's it's
being well catered for but but not about
that mate
if you knew what you knew now would you
have still tried to play that quarter
final
i probably i probably would have done i
probably would have done mate i just
love playing i love playing
i'm not you know you're you're i feel
like you're you're a rugby thinker right
you're
you're you're you're a good analyst
you're you probably be
an incredible coach um you you love this
sort of reading of the game
understanding it and all that the
idiosyncrasies the laws i just
loved playing yeah i wasn't really that
fussed about the laws you know it's
probably
you know probably showed in my style of
play and the number of penalties
um yeah just love that
how good anyway well let's go back to
the start of your career i know that
most people would have
will know a little bit of your career
because they've read your book
but take us back to the young louis
moody what was it like for you growing
up
mate it was uh it was simple i just you
know we had uh we had school
i found rugby when i was five so one of
the lads matt foster
um it was a guy that introduced me to it
and you know rugby back then was full
contact from
at the moment he played which you know
which appealed which appealed to my uh
my style of uh exuberance and enthusiasm
and
plus i was you know as a kid i was i was
pretty i was
i was massive compared to the other kids
so it was significantly easier for me i
imagine
it sees in your book that you're a back
or did you just make that up because you
forgot
nothing i was a center i was a center
until the year before i made my
premiership debut and then they realized
that i couldn't catch or you know
start stop racing oh [ __ ] was it that
long i didn't realize you were
back till that late yeah so i uh so i
was playing
school first team at center and then one
of my i went to the county trial
you know trying to trying to make it so
we have over here
well back then we had county she had
school club
county um regional and then you had like
england school boys and what have you
so county was like the first step on the
ladder for me and
and i didn't get an under 16 so i
thought definitely getting out under
18's didn't
didn't again well i went to the trial
and and thankfully one of my coaches
were two coaches brian welford and uh
and
andy wilson home were two guys that were
like we should try him at blanket and i
got moved during this one game
and i have to admit even for me it was
like an epiphany it was like wow
get this all of a sudden i'm just i'm
just following the ball around
and tackling people this is like the
best thing ever
and uh and that was it mate so i was you
know from from the age
of five to seventeen i was i was a
center
and loved it you know just loved getting
muddy loved tackling
loved the whole team ethos and um
you know grew up watching leicester
tigers you know i went to oakland school
but my first team coach was ian dawson
smith who i'm sure
no one in new zealand will remember but
he was a he was a leicester tigers
um stalwart and legend and and he sort
of
nudged me off to leicester um when i
finished school
and said go on as an 18 year old sort of
kid see how you get on i weighed about
13 stone
you know even back then in 1996 that was
still pretty light for a back row
i remember i remember i remember i
remember going into my first game so i
played my first game for leicester
tigers thinking that
you know i had all the confidence the
bravado of you know as a public school
boy
you know come through the england
schools that from that county trial
ended up playing england schools that
year and then played england schools
uh 21s and all that sort of stuff and so
wow yeah this is great i'm going to show
these boys how it's done
and uh oh mate i was i was absolutely
village it was like
i felt like a school boy in a you know
it was like being a rag doll
felt like a child just getting kicked up
and thrown around
the worst bit about it was there was a
guy called dean richards who was an
england player
you know of great renown at that point
and he was our captain and sort of a
schoolboy hero of mine actually grew up
watching him he played in the 91 world
cup final against australia
and he sort of gathered us all in and
you know he's like right that's whatever
you do you know you keep holding the
ball
you know when that kickoff comes to us
you keep hold of it we drive you know we
get joel strands give us our fly off at
the time yeah
yeah you get the ball into joel and
he'll clear the lines and we'll get down
the other end put some pressure on score
some points you know we were like 15
15 nil down in my first every game for
less abs
right right right and i was listening as
a school boy like just in the huddle was
like martin johnson joel stratsky rory
and with dean richards who
were like all my school boy heroes like
watching these guys playing world cups
and i'm really not taking anything in so
the first kickoff came to me
and uh you know dean's like keep it keep
hold of it drive it
old-school rugby and um came to me and i
caught it and i was pretty quick back
then jimmy
and uh caught it sidestep and ran off
and like there was a guy called frano
bosco do you remember frank what again
so yeah
and i say league league legend in union
legend and uh
and he was playing for oral at the time
and uh and as i
as the sort of pitch opened up and i
made a sidestep i thought i was like
going to go the length of the pitch and
you know change the course of the game
scoreboard heroes
yeah but as i thought that as i thought
that frantica like
scrag tackled me and uh and as i was
going down i thought right
maybe like dina's going keep hold of the
ball right drive it keep it
get it down the other end joel kick it
down the other end we'll put pressure
down there
get some points on the board as i was
getting scragged tackled by friend of
ottawa i was thinking in my head i was
like right
martin johnson's running a perfect line
off my shoulder here
and uh i'm going to give what i thought
i did give what i thought was a lovely
little flick out the back of my hand and
watched it
because i rolled around and watched it
all the way until it hit jono directly
in the forehead
which was to be fair it was difficult to
miss because he got a massive fight but
you know and the ball there bounced
forward and i was like oh they picked up
and scored under the post so i was like
oh no oh no and you know in my head i'm
thinking right these you know i'm sure
everyone's cocked up before
you know you know they must have been
there made a mistake
you know i'm a young lad first game i'm
sure they'll be supportive
jono just literally looked over at me
like literally staring at me
i'm still on the floor like picked me up
by the scruff of the neck
and said i told you to hold on to the
ball and then other words that i
probably won't use on here
but it's safe to say i didn't get to
play again for about another
year and a half until i learned my
lesson keep hold of the ball don't ever
try and pass it
basically was the lesson well it's
brutal
but you were hey so you're 18 years old
when you made your debut
it's with all these leaders it's crazy
yeah and it was obviously a way more
old-school rugby environment back then
um such an intimidating environment for
a kid like you how did you find the
whole off-field side of the team
um as an 18 year old when you come into
a group of men essentially like that i
found
yeah it was it was tough i loved it you
know don't get me wrong i did love it
but it was it was
it was intimidating probably for all the
right reasons right because
you know i i felt nervous because these
guys are all i've been i've grown up
watching them they're like my heroes um
you know there were a couple of guys
that were they were great as i had two
mates while so
i had two mates that sounded like
obviously more than that in life
but you know at the time just the two
and
there's a guy called leon lloyd who you
know who's one of my closest mates and
uh
you know grew up playing together went
through all the county system and uh and
we were in the squad together
um but apart from us that was that was
pretty much it the rest were this sort
of seasoned old school that had come
through the amateur era
that was the first season of it was the
first full season of professional rugby
um it was an intimidating place right it
was intimidating place you felt like you
sort of
you didn't speak in you know until
you've spoken to type thing or you
didn't speak until you during your
stripes and
you know that was fine you just cracked
on and i i was never
i was always a pretty shy kid anyway to
be honest and i just wanted my sport to
do the talking and eventually
it did you know university derailed me
for a little bit during that first year
and i got caught up
maybe enjoying myself rather too much
and sidestracked from uh training and
all that sort of stuff but
when i was late for my first appraisal
you know like player appraisal yeah um
i was we'd gone out the night before and
i'd completely forgotten i had it
as a naive 18 or it would have been 19
then so it's the end of the season yeah
and my housemate got a phone call
and he was like uh dean richards is on
the phone apparently you're supposed to
be in a meeting
i was like and uh
ran down ran down the stairs i'd left my
car in town
and it's like a 10-minute drive to the
training ground and thankfully my
housemate had his car there but he only
had
one leg because he had an accident as a
kid so his pedals were
reversed so the brake was the
accelerator and the accelerator was a
break and this sounds like a comedy
sketch right
it was that was carnage i was like how
am i going to try
so i was trying to get out oh man it was
it was a cut it literally was a car
crash waiting to happen
i don't know how i made it to training i
made it to training after like
bunny hopping up the road for that and
uh and i got there i walked in and they
just literally
as soon as i walked in they went get out
and um
made me sit outside for about 15 minutes
and you talk about old school rugby
mates old this is old school rugby saved
my career essentially as an 18 year old
lost naive schoolboy that was just
enjoying himself and didn't understand
what professional rugby was about
um so i sat outside they said come in
there was joel stransky dean richards
and john wells who were the coaching
staff at the time
and joel stratsky actually asked you
know who's like right can you can you
lift your top up
because they've been talking about diet
and nutrition and obviously i'd not been
adhering to that as a student
and i think joel you know wanted to
impress on me the fact that i was
essentially a flabby
you know teenager still so i left him i
lifted my shirt up and and
running literally from my shoulder to my
to my hip
with three massive like stunt marks and
uh and and wellesley and wells you just
went
and that's the reason we're keeping you
lad but that's the only reason
i promise i'm going to get it right next
year but it was
it was a it was a good it was a good
lesson like i was
you know i was a public school boy i was
i'd gone from all the rules and
regulations of school
to suddenly being free out in the world
and just
just embracing life and you know i yeah
i got it wrong that first year i
did too much partying too much you know
enjoying myself and not focusing enough
on being a sportsman and
even in my actually in my first england
tour
you know which was uh 1998 so a year and
a half later
you know i was i was still battling that
that mentality i was trying to be
professional but i was also
wanting to fit in and all that sort of
stuff so after that
98 season i finally you know put all
that behind me and just
focused on you know playing the game and
being being a professional but
you know trying to find that balance
when you were a young kid and the game
was switching from amateur to
professionals was tricky
and you obviously um you did it with
success you ended up playing
over 200 games for leicester tigers and
winning about a thousand premierships
and a fair bit of heineken cup success
as well do you want to talk through
any of those um ones that stand out for
you well mate bizarrely actually the one
the one i enjoyed the most probably was
was one i played
zero minutes in i was on i was on a
bench in in the heineken cup finals so
the european final
so from 98 to 2002 we'd we'd won
four back-to-back premiership titles you
know so we were we were just all we're
unbeaten at welford road which is the
tigers home ground for
for four seasons yeah for it was four
and a half years actually ended up being
and during all those all that success
and i had a you know had a big role to
play in a lot of that
you know sometimes i was in sometimes
out we had so we had two guys like josh
cromfeld come over and play in the back
row we had neil back
martin curry you know guys that are all
world class players
um so there's a huge amount of
competition per place so
and a lot of changing took place as well
so come the heineken cup final in 2001 i
actually i was on the bench
and and i didn't get a single minute but
the build-up to that had been we'd
we'd gone to uh the heineken cup fine 98
um we'd won the league we've got to the
we played it in cardiff arms park you
know precursor to the millennium stadium
or now the principality
we lost that to breathe and we believed
were the best side
in in europe for a long time yet we we
weren't able to win
um the heineken cup you know bath won it
in 98 and
you know they couldn't get anywhere near
us in the league at that time
so it was a real um you know sort of
monkey on the back
and you know leicester leicester's a
real old school
club or it was then in the best sense of
of the meaning of the word old school in
that everyone that was around the club
had been a part of the club they played
you know the coach and the chairman
um the md the ceo they'd all been former
players you know the kit man
uh the physio you know the only the only
guy that
uh you know actually one of the physios
is probably one of the only guys that
hadn't actually been a player so the
whole backroom staff
knew what it was about to play for the
tigers and
there was there was this just built up
to this game was just massive there was
so much pressure on us and we were so
brilliant and
through the year but we hadn't been able
to nail the huntington cup when we get
to the final we're playing stad francais
in france like in the stad de france not
you know not a neutral venue basically
playing it
in their home stadium and we you know i
think that got our ankles up a bit but
we were just desperate to prove that we
were that we should be up there and
recognize as one of the best sides in
europe and although i didn't play a
single minute in that game
you know being a part of that squad on
that day and how much it meant i've
still got the ball
up on the shelf up behind me from that
match day and it's got all the players
with the entire squad
but all the back room stuff so the guys
like peter wheeler pete tom
john duggan cliff shepard who is a kit
man for
donkeys sadly no longer with us and you
know he would he was great because he
would give austin healy stick
all the time because he was a winger as
well and
and austin never scored as many tries as
him so you know he'd do stuff like not
not
not put his shirt out on time or hide it
and oh it's just brilliant
but you know having something like that
that was so important to the entire club
even though i didn't play a single
minute
that's what made the game for me being a
part of something with a club that i
loved with people that i loved playing
for
um that made you feel special that made
you feel a part of something
more more than just a game it just felt
massive and i'm sure
jimmy you know as a as a born and bred
kiwi man you guys seem to
understand that better than anyone and i
think as a club at leicester we
we really we really knew what that meant
and it was a real special time to play
the game you know i absolutely
loved those years at the tigers and you
know
the the parties after were pretty
enjoyable
but that's a pretty powerful um culture
that you've obviously developed at
leicester because i mean most teams are
trying to replicate that some teams can
replicate but not every team can because
people
put themselves first but then you
obviously went on to
become captain of leicester may i didn't
i'd well i was
i i was captain of leicester for for
only a couple of games so
i was never i was never club captain and
that's actually something i
i really regretted during my career
because i did go on to become england
captain
um and because i was i think it was just
because i was inherently shy i genuinely
believed that i wasn't
gonna be good enough as a captain that
when i was when i was offered it you
know or when it was suggested to me or
i was just inherently nervous i had that
fear of failure thing right i just
i was i was worried about doing it even
though i'd kept in my school boy sides
and you know representative sides
for whatever reason uh you know it made
me nervous i did it on a handful of
occasions for
for leicester and and i thoroughly
enjoyed it and one actually one of my
biggest regrets jimmy
is you know getting to captain england
as
you know for the last two seasons of my
international career
was was just incredible but you also
learned so much i remember listening to
richie mccoy talk about his you know
lessons from 2007 and you know
how he how it helped him grow and
develop and understand himself better as
a captain and i think
you know for me i had exactly the same
lessons
taught to me and i learned through
failing many times over again and making
poor decisions and you know not
delegating enough taking on tourists too
much responsibility therefore your form
dips you know and all these sorts of
things you sort of learn
and i got to a point where at you know
32
i was like you know i've now i now feel
like i'm ready to
to to be a captain but you know my time
my time had come and gone in
an england shirt and you know i knew it
as well i knew there were better players
than me around
and um you know i i had to put my hands
up and say look it's time for me to step
away and you guys need to take over but
i wish i had so my regret is i wish i'd
had the confidence as a kid to take that
responsibility on earlier
and not and not doubt myself right you
know there's and there's so much great
stuff going on in the world about mental
health and well-being and
you know kindness and confidence and
actually you know you need that you need
to give yourself some self-love you know
you need to
you need to have that inner belief which
i think we all do as athletes right you
have an inner belief in your own
personal ability
yeah i think but around certain elements
it can maybe wane and for me it was
definitely around that leadership piece
is worrying whether
i'd be good enough but i'm glad i did it
you know those two years were
a rollercoaster ride with england of
being australia in australia
winning the six nations and then
obviously uh you know
getting uh getting kicked out of the
world cup in in 2011 by france so
it was yeah and all the fallout from
that so that was that was the lows
but it was it was still an enjoyable
experience well let's get to your
england career
obviously very successful career with
england the national side
um start with your debut how was it
going into the england camp for the
first few times and
how was that very first game in the red
rose jersey
well you sound like you're slightly
jealous that you know it's not that you
wish you'd filled it on youtube
i still got one of your jerseys i wear
it most nights
in bed riley loves that
i've given one to all the family or this
is probably the point we should say yeah
that you know the fact that you're
actually a a relative
is you know is incredible but i have
given
you know you're not the only family
relative to to get to get a jersey
johnny our other brother-in-law
but um i can't remember what you asked
me that would you ask me
um how was your first year yeah it was
terrifying
it was terrifying actually going into
the camp for the first time is
terrifying the only easy bit
you know when you when you're going into
a new environment uh you know
with the best players in the country you
just want to impress right you want to
get everything
you want to get everything right and you
know it was a clive at that time
was was building a a really unique squad
a unique team
managers and you know and i was lucky
that in 2001 i sort of dropped in just
at the right time and all of this was
gradually coming together
this big plan was was was being hatched
but it wasn't it made it
just terrifying you know i was lucky in
the fact that i had a load of estimates
there
you know that uh that i played with week
in week out that was that was the
godsend but your first camp is
terrifying
um you know you just desperately want to
impress
and uh and my first cap
actually turned out to be not that not
that scary my first cap at twickenham
was was terrifying i remember feeling
sick before the game and
you know jono just coming up to me don't
worry mate you'll be fine you'll be fine
and
and i actually ran out to the pitch and
and the smoke sort of blinded me
momentarily ended up running onto the
you know they have all the big flags out
the [ __ ]
i ended up running out onto one of the
flags i was like where'd they go
where'd everyone go um but but my first
my first cap was was against
canada in i mean it was literally in a
field
like in the back of some farmyard
essentially
in uh in vancouver um yeah so
you know you have great you have great
visions of making your debut
you know um you know wherever
cardiff arms twickenham you know um
but for me it was literally a farmer's
field and they were about
i mean there might have been 500 people
watching um
we beat canada we beat canada um
and it was actually a great tour mate i
loved it and you know it was the first
time i felt like a professional you know
there was no
all the other you know a lot of the
other lads were it was still you know
midweek
drinks nights or you know if the the
lads that weren't involved obviously in
the match we were going out midweek um
and all that sort of jazz but it was the
first time i was
you know i felt like a proper dedicated
professional was focused on what i
wanted to do i was up early in the pool
recovery
you know eating all the boiled chicken
and the oily fish and
you know all the all the good stuff that
was happening
at that time i actually thought it was
it was great and my leicester coach was
the england coach at the time forwards
coach john wales
that was pretty cool because i i played
my first game oral the one i told you
about when i had a shocker
with him and uh and i had a lot of
respect for him he was a hard-nosed
old-school coach but he he was brilliant
because he told you straight right
a lot of coaches sort of beat around the
bush if you get dropped or
or aren't honest with you and he was
brilliant like if he got dropped i would
just say mate
i think i'm playing well why why haven't
he picked me he'd be like well
you know you you don't do this as good
as the guy
that i picked ahead of you i was like
okay that's fair enough i'm gonna have
to go
and work on that yeah so he gave you he
gave you good valid reasons and stuff
that you go and actually improve on and
say look i'm doing this better now
please bit me
but so to be presenting my shirt by by
wells he was uh was pretty cool the
night before the game
um and it still meant the fact that it
was on a farmer's field in the middle of
vancouver it still meant as much to me
as it would have done
if you know if it had been twickenham
stadium it was you know it was
super special and i played so we talked
about leon lloyd and my best mates i
grew up with
he was also on that tour so made my
debut with him
and i've still got a picture on the wall
of us too after that match which was
which is pretty cool back in
back in 2001. oh good and then obviously
you went pretty well over the next
couple years and made the
and england itself went pretty well as
well made the world cup
2003 world cup you were the winners
want to talk about that tournament and
the lead up to that
man it was um you know as i said that
that sort of 2001 coming into that
england team at that time and there were
so many wonderful
world-class players and he had laurence
delaila richard hill neil back was
you know was the starting back row that
i was trying to break into
um johnny wilkinson matt dawson um phil
vickery jason leonard you know
the team was just proliferated with
world-class players and kieran bragging
even in
multiple players in multiple positions
you know which is what you need to be a
world-class competitive side and
it was i have to admit i was it was a
real
i enjoyed my rugby at that point i
enjoyed going to camp it was it was it
was hard you know as it should be you
know we worked
we worked brutally hard because we knew
we had two goals was being the fittest
team in the world and being the best
prepared
um you know we we set about being the
fittest obviously and working with all
the strength and conditioning coaches
and
putting in the extra hours so when you
finish training at the club
you were doing more you know it wasn't
about being fitter than the guy at your
club or the guy that's
pushing you in england it was about
being fitter than essentially richie
mccoy for me
you know which was a big ass because he
was a hugely fit human being
but uh i don't think i ever quite
achieved that
but i was working towards it i was
working towards it but we all we all had
that we all had that mindset right it
was just everyone was pushing everyone
and that competitive spirit
that competition for place just pushed
everyone and there was no way
there was no moment where you could rest
on your laurels and
and feel like your place was guaranteed
no matter who you were so
it was it was a cool period of time and
you know
we we we went through all the games the
the really
the the bit that really stands out in my
mind though right is there's two bits
one is that
clive the manager clive woodward and you
know he's
you know whether he's your cup of tea or
not as a manager or whatever he you know
he's gone and done
he's been brilliant at the time he was
brilliant as well you know
what i felt clive recognized really
quickly was that his strengths and his
weaknesses
he understood straight away and that
maybe he wasn't the world cast
coach that he wanted to be and although
he did do
you know a lot of the coaching he got
him a world-class coaching side he
realized he was a world-class manager
essentially
yeah um and then he set about building
this incredible
team around in the support network this
you know backroom staff that
it meant if we got to a world cup final
there was going to be no reason we could
look back and go well if we just had
that
we would have won you know we had every
everything was catered for it covered
every eventuality he thought you know he
was just a great thinker you know he
would try anything
if he thought it would work and it would
make one percent difference he
you know he would he would try so we had
this
great plan you know in terms of being
the fittest team the world and best
prepared and we
we set four years to achieve that and
come the world cup we were the number
one side in the world we'd be in
all the sudden hemisphere sides at home
which was huge you know it's not
something that happens
you know uh it feels like ever in this
country you know and
to do it at home and then do it away as
well that same summer
was was enormous so we went in with huge
confidence but the best
so i talked about two bits one was one
was clive and you know
him creating that strategy the culture
and understanding his strengths and
weaknesses
and getting the whole team to buy into
it and the second was that when
we we realized we'd you know the whole
plan had come to fruition were the best
side in the world going to the world cup
having me knocked out by south africa in
the quarterfinal 99 to 900 drop girls
from yanni to bear
um it was a classic game uh
you know clive cliving the coaches knew
he could win the world cup ultimately
you know as i'm sure this is what it's
like to be a a kiwi going to a world cup
your number one side in the world every
time and
it shows you how hard it is to win
because you guys have one every time but
so we knew
we knew we were good enough to be in the
final yeah and
it was going to be our second final so
the coaches went away and looked at all
other
you know was it super bowl world cup
football finals cricket finals
anything that you know was uh was
as an important match as this was going
to be and tried to find
something within it that um you know
that would that would link across all of
them and invariably what they decided
and what the outcome
was from their research was that it
it normally came down to the last minute
or one big play you know it rarely was a
final no matter who was in it
massively one-sided of course it was
occasionally but
yeah so we knew that it was going to
come down to that last minute and a half
doesn't matter who we played the fact
that we played australia and actually on
the day we were much better than
it still came it was still the closest
games ever
and um you know we rehearsed for the
last
two three months of training for that
world cup because
we were in such a good spot we rehearsed
every possible outcome that we would
need in the last minute and a half of
the game to win
and not just sort of go through it you
know just passing it through the hands
going through the motions against live
opposition
for like 20 minutes at a time absolutely
battering each other until we got it
right and we got it wrong lots and lots
of times
so come the world cup final in 2003 and
you know johnny wilkinson's obviously
everyone in the world knows that we're
gonna
in the last minute and a half we're
going to try and kick a drop goal you
know and get johnny and the you know
even the aussies knew that we'd
rehearsed it a million times we knew
what was going to be needed and there
was no pressure you know i came off the
bench
as a 24 year old you know very
exuberantly enthusiastic and also
absolutely crappy himself because the
game was so close
the 2003 final if you remember it like
it's sea sword
right so elton flatland johnny wilkinson
kicked both their points
they were machines that day and i was on
the bench just
you know i don't know whether you've
felt this jimmy but when you're on the
bench right it's tough you just want to
get on you want to make a difference and
then
if the game's close you sort of well in
my head i was like yeah the gremlins
do i want to be the person that gives
away the penalty and cost england the
world cup
but um mate once you're on the pitch you
cross that white line it's
it's all history it was an incredible
experience that world cup was incredible
being that four year journey
to that world cup or three years for me
from 2001 was uh
the singly most enjoyable you know
experience i had on a rugby pitch with
with all those individuals
and you came on in that final made a
couple of big plays from henry too
oh mate i don't know whether they're a
big players you you
you do you a bit don't you you know you
you come on um
i was but but it was i was just
literally doing my job man i was
i was so enthusiastic i wanted to be on
from the first minute so i had a lot of
energy to to exude in uh
in the ten minutes or whatever it was
that i was on
you know i made a lot of tackles you
know first play
the lineups overthrown i'm supposed to
lift at the back i recognize it's going
over the top
ball lands in my hands and you're into
the match straight away so it's perfect
so so so big yeah i mean three side
steps uh
hand off and then you know goose stepped
down the wing uh there's five yards from
the try like no
that's not what happened sadly um but i
had i had one i had one involvement that
was was my sort of trademark which was
trying to get to that charge down and
we knew so lawrence gave away a penalty
uh which allowed out flatly to kick
to perth's level with a minute and a
half left and um and under the post jono
is just like little as we know what
we're doing we'll keep the ball long
moodle
you'll put pressure on rogers and uh
hopefully he'll scuff it
because of that and you know we'll go to
our pattern which is which is zigzag and
that was about just
working in the middle of the pitch to
get johnny in a position for the drop
going
i put i put a bit of pressure on rogers
and and he scuffed it
and the mate what you don't know from
that moment on is from the line out that
ensued after that so
we had a line out matt dawson made a big
break and johnny ends up kicking the
drop goal
because everyone in the world knew that
we were trying to get johnny in the
position to give a drop goal
we needed to get out so if the aussies
congregated around the breakdown
to try and you know charge him down put
pressure on him
then johnny needed to get out so from
that line out i had to hold my width on
the right hand side of the pitch
and i was johnny's get out for that
crossfield kick and
um yeah if you've got the video you've
got the vhs
then you can put the tape in and uh and
you'll see that there's there's a
bondhead young
flanker still on the bottom right hand
corner of your screen
like waving his arms frantically he's
like i saw my own world cup moment of
glory
and uh and yeah i was a little bit
disappointed when johnny slotted the
drop goal i thought you selfish well
guys
oh that's classic and then how were the
celebrations after that
winning a world cup's obviously the
pinnacle of the game must have been
surreal may it was surreal do you know
what no one
like you guys with the hurricanes won
the one the super rugby title right so
you felt similar um i think whenever you
win anything there's that immediate
exuberation right the whistle goes the
yeah the instant euphoria that natural
release
um you know of all the pressure and
anxiety and buildup
of you know dreams and aspirations and
all that sort of stuff and then
when you come off the pitch having you
know done the lapse of honor and paraded
the cup and yeah
you know sung we are the champions or
whatever it is that you're seeing i
think you guys have better songs in new
zealand we just
we just have champions champions that's
it that's all people sing when they win
but no no one prepares you for what the
feeling is like when you go back inside
like so when you've done all that
and you know the crowd sort of died down
you're going to change your room
i felt this like real like numbness
it was just like yeah it felt really
weird like you sort of felt like we
should all be dancing and you know
dropping out some shapes and there
should be a boom box on and
we didn't have any of that it was you
know we just sort of sat there there was
you know someone brought in some beers
and we had a we're having a
we're having a beer and was chatting to
martin corey and jono
i just felt weird i just i didn't know
how to feel after every
big win we had during my career i felt
exactly the same i found it really hard
to
feel inspired or you know
excited after that initial exuberance
and i don't know whether it's because
you exert so much into winning in those
big games that actually all of a sudden
you've just burnt yourself out
but yeah so i always find it quite hard
to go out after after a game
my next day like it tended to be you
know
an early start so after the world cup
final we we
myself steve thompson joe wesley beck
and cohen went out the front door
once we got through the small crowd that
was there wandered down to the
the beach hide some surfboards had about
three or four gin and tonics before we
went out
like 9 30 in the morning and
uh it was it was brilliant because we
didn't have
all the crazy media attention because
obviously the aussies were so
desperately disappointed they lost it
was like it never happened
yeah you know we had the the tight
nucleus of england fans that were still
there
um but so we could just enjoy ourselves
as a unit
um and we you know we we had a good all
day i think mike tyndall met
his uh his future teacher wife zara
that night the night of the world cup
final jace leonard
jason and a few of the other boys ended
up getting bought home in a in a police
car because they couldn't find any taxis
um you know that was the the usual the
usual stuff it's
yeah it was it was no it was nothing it
wasn't like tom brady i watched the
video tom brady winning the super bowl
with the bucks recently
do you see that so what is he doing
there's a sort of stuff you can do right
when you when he won he won
seven was it six suppose he's got that
yeah they got it yeah
you know finals are one in there and by
small moments you've practiced it
endlessly over the last four years and
then you're in another final
this time against south africa yeah
but you obviously come out on the wrong
side this time talk to me about that one
mate well this was this was like a whole
different kind of fish this world cup
for us because
after 2003 you know clive left
um andy robinson took over whose
brilliant coach incredible forwards
coach
um you know but essentially inherited
the same setup same staff
minus a lot of the retired players you
know so jason
johno you know heaps of boys were
injured
and it was a really difficult
period after after that world cup and so
we came into
2007. you know andy robinson really
was released from his contract six
months before we got to
the world cup so everything that had
been built over three years was suddenly
gone
brian ashton came in who who was a
completely different thinker you know
robbo was very similar to clive
brian was very much you know just you
know play we see guys
which is great you know and and and
refreshing
and brilliant for for a lot of players
but when you're a side that's
still got the nucleus of all those
players that have played
you know four years before and a lot of
guys have gone through that system
which was very structured you know
defensively and in attack
yes there was you know when when when it
was open play it was play we see but
there was a lot of structure to it so we
we really struggled i think with
the way that brian would have played so
we came to that tournament like we
i think we finished fourth or fifth in
the six nations um
we had no no real form you know prior to
2003 we'd won the grand slam
you know we'd we'd be in all the
southern hemisphere sides we're number
one in the world
i think we were like yeah eight nine
tenth in the wild at this point
and i i don't think and you know we were
all
we all fiercely believed that we were we
were better than we were playing
but you know we had a new coach things
weren't gelling and after so our second
game we narrowly beat
america in the first game phil vickery
our tour captain
was uh was banned from tripping
for tripping one of the american players
in that game so it wasn't exactly a
great start to the tournament
um we then uh we then went to play south
africa without our captain
the the following week we lost 36 nil
which was like a record defeat
yeah and you know so we're at that point
we we were
sort of like all over lads you know a
lot of the guys that already sort of
packed their bags feeling like it was
time to go
um but we had we had like uh we had a we
had a meeting afterwards and
it was one of those honesty sessions
right that you're having
not always in times of crisis sometimes
yeah sometimes when you're on the front
foot but um
but it was perfect you know it just
brought everyone together there was a
there was a lot of finger pointing there
was a lot of uh
um you know we need to do this better um
and ultimately we just came to decision
that we need to focus on one simple
thing
gaming came out and we need to play
better than we are because you know
we're letting ourselves down at this
time
and you know the coaches brought into it
we literally focused on one
area of the game that was it that was
all our week was built around so
against australia in the quarterfinal
they'd had a they
smashed everyone they played wales fiji
and someone else so they hadn't had
particularly tough games but they were
annihilating them with amazing plays
but john wells noticed that they weren't
having to commit anyone to the ruck to
win the ball so
our simple focus was just smash the
rucks
every ruck and we did and you know we
beat australia by a point now
no one expected us to do that you know
we were the only people who believed we
we we could do it um and we probably
didn't deserve to do it but we just had
this
you know sheer bloody mindedness as a
group of players that knew were
underperforming and knew we could do
better we just had to take
control of it and it worked you know we
ended up being france in their home
stadium in the semi-final you know josh
lucy scored early on
good good bounce of the ball gets past
uh
i can't remember i was gonna say your
memory's on fire if you remember that
but oh
yeah i completely i can picture him i
can't remember his name
um but yeah so all of a sudden so we
lose 36 notes in africa
in the in the pool game all of a sudden
we're in a world cup final
playing south africa it's like so i
think in many ways you know
the journeys were totally different but
in many ways our 2007
winning the world cup you know we'd won
the world cup by getting to the final
for us we'd gone through so much getting
there
you know the the chaos before the change
of coaches the the disarray when we were
in camp and the
you know the crosswise with players and
coaches and
you know it for whatever reason it just
it just came together in those last
three games you know that singular focus
you know the french game was just
applying pressure to boxes who'd come in
as a young
fly half and in every game he'd kicked
ham you know 10 12 15 20 points
from drop kicks penalties so we just we
just
refused to allow him to kick the ball so
my job was singularly to put pressure on
his kicking game
which i absolutely loved it and that was
great fun for me
so i did that all day didn't touch the
ball or pass or anything it just changed
chased the fly off jimmy and you were
still suffering from your
you would have still been suffering from
your head knocks because this was the
same time
yeah so the so the aussie gang came
directly after the tonga match yeah
like i said i i got through there i i
generally felt
no life from i tried yeah a i was lucky
to get picked
off the bench to play that tonic game i
was then lucky to
to make it through that tonguing game
alive quite frankly yeah
um and then and then to to come out the
back of it and pass all the
all the tests to allow me to play um
that was really cool and you know jason
robinson who tore his hamstring in there
in the south africa game where we got
smashed
he thought his tournament was over and
he was stuck on 49 caps
so the only way he would get to 50 is if
we made it to the the semi-final or the
final
yeah and so that was that was pretty
cool to be able to run out with him on
his 50th cap
um you know because he was he was a
special player man you know
and i've watched some some great new
zealand players over the years you know
glenn osborne i remember when he came
on the scene he was just interning but
jason robinson
playing with him he was just so classy
he was so close was he
uh one of the most gifted players you've
played with so he wasn't the most
naturally skillful player yeah like he
was
unbelievably powerful he could he could
literally change direction at full speed
but not like
over half a meter he'd like move like it
seemed like 15 meters away
he's just i mean he was just incredible
like
he you just can't teach that it was just
something that was so exciting to watch
and to be a part of when you were in the
team with him you just knew he could
find space anywhere um you know but the
most the most talented guy
i ever witnessed play the game that i've
ever played with was jordan murphy
it was irish international played with
him for a long time at leicester and
he's a good man but he was
he played gaelic football right and then
so the gaelic football
if the ball is moving towards you you
can't pick up with your hands you have
to kick it into your hands
so it's you know like a little chip kick
which for you mate you're probably like
that sounds really easy
but for me that would be like i'd fall
over 25 times before i got to it just
thinking about it
but i remember we played a game i played
a game
whoever it was against leicester or
welford road they
they kicked the ball uh out of their 22
and so their winger could run onto it
which he was
at pace and jordan was sprinting flat
out to the ball from full back in the
opposite direction
and as you're getting there normally
you're going to make you're going to
make a decision right you'll slow down
you're going to drop on the ball
you'll fly hack it through you'll slow
down because the other guy is going to
beat you do it then you're going to have
to tackle him whatever it might be
he did not break sprint flat out this
ball was bouncing
towards him flat out with the winger
chasing him he just
chipped it at full speed into his hands
chipped the full back
and scored in the corner it was yeah it
was just one of those things
it probably doesn't sound great now but
if you even if you see it now it's an
incredible piece of skill
and he could just do crazy stuff man i
love i love playing with
i love being surrounded by people that
are infinitely more talented than me
right
because it tends to make you look much
better as a player because
you have to do a lot less 100 percent
did you find the higher
the level you went up the sort of easier
your role was 100
because everyone's doing but everyone's
doing their job properly you know it's
just they're focused on doing their job
as best as they can and they're normally
doing it really really well so therefore
you're just
only having to concentrate on doing your
bit of the game as well as you can i
said it can't be any easier whereas
sometimes with club or you know anywhere
else yeah yeah
you're going to make those offlines
you're going to make up the other stuff
i know i'd say i'd say the best out of
myself but i love playing
the game like and when i'm when i say
the game i know i love tackling
i love chasing people down like pressure
in the opposition but i love to play as
well and like as a kid
i played so much seven sevens was
was my life you know i loved it because
you had so much open space you know
you know i wasn't gifted sidestepper but
i was pretty quick as a kid and i had
a pretty good hand so i loved playing
again one actually another one of my
regrets was that
i think probably because i've played for
a club like leicester for so long
that towards the latter stages of my
career you you got very nervous about
actually trying
to do offloads and all that sort of
stuff because the
the meetings on monday the amount of
abuse you get if someone went wrong you
know it just
it almost put you off and and i have to
admit that
frustrates me and i resent that a little
bit imagine the player you would have
been if you played super rugby
oh mate imagine you know dan carter
there was i was a center mate you never
know
no i think i was destined to be a
flanker that's fight me and i loved it
yeah for sure and then let's go let's
skip another four years
your world cup this time your captain of
england
coming to the mighty new zealand to take
on
the world cup again talk me through that
well again mate a totally different um
keller fest right so we we come in
actually we're in really good form
uh we've had a good run of games we had
a load of young guys coming through ben
young's dylan hartley called
courtney laws uh to name a few
and we'd won the six nations we'd be in
australia on
on our summer tour away from home so we
we were building nicely i don't think
any of us thought we were the finished
article i don't think any
you know i felt we could reach a final
but um
i knew a lot of stuff would have to fall
into place for us to do so but i knew we
had the capability of doing well
you know we'd with training camp and you
know ultimately obviously in that world
cup we
we ended up losing to france in the
quarter final a team that we shouldn't
have lost against
because we were we were much better
and i'd been classic i was recovering
from a
prior to the tournament playing you
against i own it
yeah i remember come for now yeah that's
it
i did my knee right so i missed the six
nations in the build-up so
and i think i came back for the last
game i got fit for the
final warm-up game just prior to the
world cup
playing that tweaked my knee a little
bit again so my first game
wasn't the first match of the world cup
even though i was captain of the other
side
it was uh it was the second game so mike
tyndall was the captain in that first
game so i was actually
you know in my head in the warm up to
the georgia match which was my first
start
i i felt like i tweaked my knee again
and
i went down on it and i was like man
i've just spent
two months getting back to this position
the coaches put all their faith in me
the physios have worked enormously hard
and in the
moment before my first game in the world
cup as captain
i thought my knee had gone again and uh
and thankfully it hadn't it was just one
of those you know sometimes you come
back from an injury you know it just
feels a bit glitchy and yeah and it was
once it got into the game it was uh it
was fine
um but we spent we spent a lot of build
up to that world cup also talking about
new zealand and the pressure cooker that
it is is a
you know as a rugby environment because
you know so much
of the of the media spotlight is on
rugby right so as england players coming
to new zealand
you know the the media attention was
going to be on us as well you know mike
tyndall obviously just
married into the royal family as well so
that was creating big news
um and like in any campaign you you
spend
two to three months building up to the
the tournament
so you're away from family you're
working hard all that jazz
and you always target a window during
the
as an england team this is what we did
we targeted a window
normally after uh an easier game so
after the georgie it was in georgie i
think it was the george again but um
we were going to have a you know an
evening off we'll have training off the
next day and then we'll be able to go
and let her down
yeah and uh and that's and that's what
we did and
you know sadly you know a few people got
caught in uh
in awkward situations and
the media was just honest so despite the
fact that we spent three months going
right guys it's gonna be a media
you know media hotspot um the
attention's all gonna be on us you know
you've got to be super careful where you
gotta
um you know whatever you do we literally
repeatedly when we got there we repeat
it
you know it felt like too much
to the point where you just feel like
you're saying it right and
to still come unstuck because of
something that we bought on ourselves i
think
was is the biggest frustration for me
for that world cup because
ultimately what transpired off the back
of that you know
the you know rightly or wrongly okay
ultimately we
you know a few players we all went out
we had a team meal we had a few drinks
um there were lots of nations doing it
on the same night just in the bars
around the corner
yeah um and you know for whatever reason
we have a couple of guys that ended up
getting too far and that were
you know high price profit players so
the media attention is on them and
and you know that was it you know all of
a sudden you spend
the next three four weeks talking about
just those moments and then
once one moment like that happens in a
campaign
anything else that happens that may or
may not like the borderline stuff that i
think there's something with johnny and
the balls you know whether he was
writing on the balls or something
you know um there was there was all
sorts of stuff that then grew and grew
and grew and
it was painful man as a captain you know
it's a relatively new captain so i've
done a season
the season before as england captain um
you know it was it was suddenly a lot to
burn because you're not actually
worrying about playing the game yeah
you're
having conversations with players about
what's happened the night before how
they're going to address the media
and it's just ongoing there was more
reports coming in is it
and it was it was it was hard work and
we we had to sit down and
and as captain you have to you know have
to also put your hands up afterwards and
goes
you know there was something i clearly
got wrong because
i thought we'd prepared well i thought
we had a good squad that knew what they
were doing there was a good balance of
old boys and young guys
um and and everything in between and
and we were playing well um and we
allowed
external factors to totally derail us
and i think that's what frustrates me
and
you know when you're the captain the
coach you've got to be hand up and go
you know okay look we
there's clearly stuff we should have we
should have seen coming and
and being able to avoid and i think
probably coming down on some of the
the players earlier prior to the tour
some of the the
you know the misdemeanors stuff that
wasn't a
wasn't a big deal but maybe in the in
the light of day you're actually going
to get
you know crack down on that hard when it
happened it sets a tone then for for the
rest you know if uh
if you let one person get away with it
other stuff
other stuff comes off the back and the
biggest disappointment then off
of the world cup was okay that's all
happened but we then play france in the
quarter final a team that
you know we could be when we knew we
could be and it's not that they were
bad side there you know they're
obviously a very good side with with
wonderful players
but we played and we had the capability
we had the players to
to win that game and we didn't and you
know
it was it was tough coming back to this
country after that and stuff and if
you're a captain
it's even tougher because the blame you
know
is is pointed and landing on your
shoulders and you have to
you know you have to you have to take it
did you feel like the
english media was harder on the england
side or on you as captain
um no i i don't think so
like we know we know what the media is
like anywhere in the world you know
america england new zealand australia
you know
and we knew it was coming it wasn't like
it was a surprise
um you know i think the the fallout from
it was there was all sorts of other
stuff that happened here you know that
you know they had this um
uh what's it called it's like a server
you know it's supposed to be an
anonymous survey you know people want to
find out what had been going on so
everyone had the ability this anonymous
survey
anonymous survey then gets leaked to the
press by the
by the people in charge of the rfu at
the time i mean it was just me you know
it's just
some horrible people involved doing
doing stuff that was
only for them to look good you know it
was uh it was a really tough time yeah
so may
for me personally was hard but you know
i don't blame the media the media they
you know it's their job right it's if
you allow them the opportunity if you
give them the stories
then you know if they're out there
creating stories then it's different but
you know we we go we gave him stuff to
write about so i've got no
i've got no qualms about that that's
good and that was your last game in the
england jersey yeah
it was me and i you know and i was
bitter about that for a long time
um because actually we didn't touch upon
leicester and my
my departure from leicester which is my
school boy club
yeah i was yeah so i i left the year
before the world cup
um when i say left i was released from
leicester so i played at leicester for
14 years i was 30 but you know i've gone
from 14 to 30 through the junior side
and
all the way through um you know i i
envisaged playing my
my sort of my time out leicester so to
to walk in on a meeting and be told that
i was surprised to requirements whilst
in the year that i was picked to be
england captain was was pretty hard pill
to swallow
um and i felt really bitter about that
for for a long time
and you know when i say a long time i
mean well into my retirement
so so i had that literally the year
before the world cup so that's still
lingering in my head and i've moved to
bath to play
which i love i'm still i still live in
bath now i love this place but
you know the rugby wasn't quite the same
and then
you know to finish your england career
so we're a decade playing for england
um you know in a world cup campaign that
ended
as it did um was was also pretty pretty
disappointing and a hard thing to
swallow but you know i
i stepped away from international rugby
as i was always going to do after that
world cup because i think as i said
earlier jimmy
you know there were better players
coming through at that time you know i
was
i was still a quality player i was still
playing well um and i thought there was
still
at least three or four more years left
in the tank yet but i wanted to
focus my attention on playing for for
the club side that put their faith in me
which was bath
um and then literally i came back from
uh from that world cup
had uh had a week or two off and and the
first game i played
was against worcester away and
obviously again so you've got all the
media attention so it was moody england
captain coming back after the you know
disastrous world cup campaign you know
he's got a point to prove blah blah blah
all this which i did i did have a point
to prove
um i went for a tap tackle on the full
back
literally just a diving tap tackle and
uh
and landed with my arm outstretched with
my weak shoulder and
so i'd had three shoulder
reconstructions and and i knew instantly
i knew instantly that was it i just knew
and i tried to play the rest of the game
with one arm essentially got knocked out
twice probably you know made it
infinitely worse for
for my team because i you know as
essentially uh
yeah not functioning correctly and uh
and with about 20 minutes to go
i was thankfully taken off and and that
was my last game of rugby so
you know the you can't you don't get to
write the endings of your careers you
know i had
the most enjoyable experience in my life
playing rugby it was awesome
but you don't get to write the happy
ending and
going out on uh lifting the world cup as
england captain
um you know i i got it a very different
way but
it doesn't make my career any less
enjoyable and i don't look back now with
any regret or bitterness anymore you
know that's that's all long gone i've
been retired nearly 10 years and
and i have a family of kids that are now
enjoying their sport and i'm watching
them and
you know and as you said i start putting
my passions into into areas of life that
that now interesting interest me and
have a huge amount of meaning and
purpose for me
yeah well let's get to that um you've
obviously set up the lewis moody
foundation you're doing all sorts of
good work
around brain tumors helping people with
brain tumors getting
uh i guess making getting the awareness
out there do you want to talk to me
about what inspired you to set up that
um
foundation and what you're actually
doing
sure man um yeah so we met actually so
it was it was
two weeks after i retired so i pulled
the pin on you know
my shoulder finally gave in i had to
press the button i think we did on
twitter actually like literally press
the button
on the computer and um and that was it
you know wake up the next day what'd you
do and i got a letter in the post
from a guy called graham stark and he
lived up in sheffield
and it said look my son's got a ref on
with cancer would you
mind helping him out coming up doing a
training session
maybe bring some kit up so he can
auction so he can send his mates off
um so we did went up met them met joss
um
leo and the family took a training
session took upload a kit they auctioned
it off
it was one of those occasions actually
you meet some people in your life and
there are there are
there are moments people sliding doors
or whatever that happen
um that just have a huge impact on you
and and this did so i kept in touch with
joss and graham for
for the next year i got another phone
call from graham well we've been
speaking all the time but my phone calls
said that the lads were struggling leo
and joss leo was
just his brother um was there anything i
could do to sort of alleviate the
boredom and monotony of
of dealing with illness um so i took him
to a game at twickenham so we had
hospitality pretty good hospitality all
the good stuff right
chose the team i knew we'd beat so pick
wales and um
but we lost them at the weekend right so
i can say that
and um and we you know we had a great
day so it took them down into changing
rooms afterwards you know all the stuff
that former
england captains you know have access to
which i felt incredibly lucky and
privileged to have done
so talking down the change rooms you
meet the current team players got by the
match afterwards hospitality the rfu
were brilliant
and you know about two days afterwards
so joss has been there and chatting to
the england players he's got
signed photos memorabilia graham his dad
called me about
it was a week and a half later and just
to mate this was perfect
like the lads elated dancing around the
house you know
josh on the day was in a wheelchair
because his illness
was um you know was was at that stage he
was he was struggling
but he was just elated off the back of
it photographs remember really of flags
scarfs everything around the house and
then at the end of the phone called you
know said
he said thank you so much and just said
i'm really sorry but josh
lost his battle with uh with cancer uh
yesterday
and and for me that was just a massive
like moment in my life it was like hey
i've got to know this guy over
over a year and a half got to know him
well he's a young lad he was only 16.
um he was an incredible sportsman
athlete rugby player
um and all of a sudden his life's been
taken from him
and i think me and annie just and my
wife just wanted
to focus all our attention on on doing
something super positive so
we set up a a charity and joss's
memory so i would call it just riley
stark
foundation but i was i was directed
differently at the time
to use my sort of name to you know
for good so okay that's we went with the
lewis movie foundation and uh
so ever since then mate we've spent five
six years
we actually launched it in 2014 so it
took me a time to get everything going
and you know we've raised nearly over 2
million all the stuff that we
we do so how we raise money for brain
tumors is by taking people on
crazy challenges to places um they're
not always crazy but
a lot of them are the first one was the
north pole that was pretty epic um
we then did a thousand miles across
vietnam and cambodia
uh we then did coast to coast costa rica
it's like crocodiles we were in the
kayaks and
bikes it was they're just mental trips
and we finished our last trip
obviously the rest have been cancelled
this year and postponed because of um
kovid but we finished thankfully we got
back from the south pole in uh
at the end of january so just in time to
to get it in and uh you know it's it's
it's been a wonderful sort of five years
the current situation has changed
everything massively charities have been
and ours has been hit
um fundraising has been decimated
um we've been able to do virtual stuff
so thankfully the light is at the end of
the tunnel you know the
vaccines and everything are in place so
we've got some other challenges and some
different means of raising money but um
but if anyone wants to look at it
because
you know in the uk anyway brain tumors
are the biggest cancer killer
of under 40s and children by none um but
until a few years ago and you receive
two percent of all funding so
around the world i think america are
leading the way with brain tumors
but um still more needs to be done and
there's always good stuff
that comes out of new zealand in terms
of research and knowledge as well so
um you know it's it's it's not a it's
not a uk-based thing it's a it's a
global thing so
the more awareness we can raise and the
more we can do for brain tumors the
better but the lewis moody
foundation.org is the website if anyone
wants to have a look at what we do
it's uh when you talk about retirement
and finding
your next thing i was super lucky that
that letter fell through my door because
the the the irony of it is that
them asking me for help essentially
helped me more than they could ever have
imagined because it gave me a purpose
post-playing
that i otherwise wouldn't have found and
uh and
i feel really lucky to have met graham
and was just
you know still in contact with him i was
chatting to him just the other day so
it's uh
you know that's really cool matt you're
doing some amazing things and yes any
water
listeners out there please go and check
that out and donate if you can i know
people with young kids i mean the idea
of them getting sick and especially
something like a brain tumor man it just
breaks your heart even thinking about
today so it's um it's incredible what
you're doing in that space
cheers jimmy yeah and if anyone wants
anyone listening i'd say come and join
us on the lions tour but uh
at the minute it doesn't look like you
know who knows where that's going to be
if it's going to happen
um i really hope it does happen because
you know even if it's not in south
africa
but um it would be a real tragedy if
that doesn't but safety first and all
that i suppose
yeah is that the next um tour for the
charity is it
well so we've got amazon we've got an
amazon tour as well but uh
that's been postponed to 2020 but the
lions obviously is
you know you can't well we can postpone
it obviously if they move it till next
year which is not a problem but if they
move
the challenge if they move the the tour
somewhere else then the challenge will
have to be cancelled but you know i'd
still love to see the
alliance to go ahead either way you know
as long as it's safe so how do you get
involved in one of those things so
obviously
all these experience like going to the
south pole and
uh doing the amazon and all that that
there's unbelievable experiences
can anyone just come in and what do you
do pay to join it do you
yeah yeah so if you go on the website
there's you know there's a whole host of
pages but if you go to the challenge
page you'll see what's what's coming up
and you literally just click on it so
all of our challenges they're not for
superhumans
far from it you know it's just about
getting from a to b from start to finish
no time there's no you know not trying
to set any records we're just trying to
get from a to b
and raise as much money as we can in the
way and hope that everyone enjoys it
it's going to be hard and it's going to
push you
but um you know we have guys that have
been sat behind a desk for 20 years and
a nearly 20 stone
and we've got super fit triathletes and
all sorts obviously and everything in
between
but it is it's epic mate and you'll have
to come
jimmy one day you know i've got
something lined up for you what have you
got i hope it doesn't involve walking
because my hip's [ __ ]
oh yeah good point i've got a nice
marathon run for you that'll be all
right
i didn't have a look at them i was like
oh a lot of them had tricks and stuff i
was like i have to wait till he gets
some sort of like
wheelchair or viking land yeah just have
to get you in a in a push chair there
you'll be fine
you can push jimmy up the hill slid to
the north pole
be good training yeah man mate but
that's unreal and
uh really appreciate you coming on the
podcast i know it's getting late over
there so wrap
that up i had so much i wanted to talk
to you about you've obviously had
an amazing career um love following your
journey since
i became your brother-in-law or even
before that um i remember playing
as you your character on rugby 08 back
in the day and
you were you were a good tackler
[Laughter]
you weren't a st you didn't even you
didn't have a star but you're you i
remember you being a real good tackler
and
i think um good at the charge down
yeah brilliant well i remembered you
know the one thing the one joyous moment
i had from 2011 world cup
was coming off the pitch afterwards when
i was pretty desolate
about the whole game and i could hear
someone shouting my name
really loud and really uh really
excitedly i was like
fair play thank you so much someone
really loves me and then i realized it
was you as well
it must have been bad i remember getting
on the partner's bus after that game
and oh my gosh it was like everyone was
in tears obviously
i was gutted for you but i didn't really
care and i was pumped
and i was in the wrong environment on
that bus
you you were pumped i remember even in
the i think we went back to the hotel
afterwards you were
yeah it was good time man i'm glad you
were there i'm glad you were there
certainly lightened
my mood well anyway
hopefully we can catch up sometime soon
once this um
covered stuff finishes and yet like i
said i'd love to
love to jump on one of those charity
things or if i can help out in any way
um you're doing amazing things in that
space i'd love to be able to help out so
let me know but really appreciate giving
up your time mate
um hell of a yarn hell of a journey what
a lead pleasure mate take care and good
luck with the podcast
generally i genuinely love it i've been
listening over here so uh so keep it
going
hopefully i've not put everyone to sleep
that's bloody
good